chris hemsworth beared it all for thor
love and thunder stripping down to
nothing right in front of russell crowe
he has everything you need to know about
what he his wife and the movie's
director had to say about it if you
caught one of the official trailers for
thor love and thunder that arrived in
late may you're probably aware of a
scene near the end of the clip that sees
thor in some sort of magical bondage
facing an olympian council headed up by
russell crowe's zeus in an ostensible
effort to reveal what thor might be
hiding under his loose-fitting cloak
zeus flicks too hard blowing the god of
thunder's garments clear across the room
thor ends up completely naked in front
of everyone in the hall causing a lot of
olympians to faint and giving a good
laugh to the audience that's the
valkyrie and jane it's the perfect time
to eat a grape and gaze and wonder at
the naked compatriot all the tight
costumes notwithstanding the marvel
cinematic universe isn't exactly known
for copious nudity so the moment is
memorable
as it turns out that is also an
important moment for hemsworth as well
while this often can be played for
laughs actually filming actors in the
nude is usually a challenge for actors
and filmmakers both after all not many
jobs ever require you to strip naked for
a day's work now hemsworth and director
taika waititi have added the god of
thunder to the annals of big screen
butts and neither of them took the scene
in question lightly chris hemsworth has
endured plenty of physical
transformations to his character during
his time playing the iconic asgardian
from simple stuff like donning an eye
patch at the end of thor ragnarok and
appearing as a more heavyset hero in
avengers end game but according to the
actor's comments to variety at the thor
love and thunder hollywood premiere
taking it all off on screen was sort of
a transformation he's been aspiring to
do since his first appearance in the
role back in 2011. as he was it it was
10 years in the making that scene kind
of a dream of mine
the first time i played four i took my
shirt off and i thought you know it's
gonna sweeten this
a decade from now it's all gonna come
off of course hemsworth isn't the only
one responsible for the naked scene so
it makes sense to ask director taika
waititi for his take on the moment too
in a clip tweeted by variety waititi
shared why it was not just desirable but
necessary for audiences to see all of
thor
we've got to show off this body yeah my
whole thing was like chris worked so
hard
you've got to show it off let's don't
cover it up with all these suits and the
cape and stuff it's not fair chris
hemsworth further discussed filming his
new scene in thor love and thunder on
australian talk show the project during
the series interview host peter helya
brought her performing opposite russell
crowe and the fact that hemsworth had to
appear naked on camera while doing so
i imagine it's pretty intimidating being
in any scene with russell crowe let
alone when you're in the buff
hemsworth joked that crow and waititi
both wore no clothes below the waist in
solidarity with the actor while they
were filming the scene in question
though his response may have been in
jest his readiness to joke about the
moment suggests that he felt little to
no reservations about stripping down in
front of the lorded actor but whom he
shared the scene on a slightly more
serious note hemsworth then revealed
that he wore a sort of modesty sock to
cover up in front of the cast and crew
members on sets that day
so for those keeping track hemsworth
wasn't completely closed-less in his
much talked-about scene but just about
as close as he could possibly be
yeah he's just a sock he wears a sock on
one ear that's his thing he's like yeah
that's gloves he thinks it's a
distraction he goes
look over here
finally during a red carpet interview
before the sydney premiere of love and
thunder hemsworth described the scene to
seven news as an altogether road affair
for both he and his family as the actor
recalled on the red carpet my wife said
yeah whatever she's seen it all before
he also mentioned that he previously
appeared nude in the formula one racing
drama rush suggesting that thor may not
even be the last time he bears it all on
camera
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]